[Music]
hello and welcome to the dead stream my
name is Susie and I will be your host
this episode and I'm joined this
afternoon by the bluff of nightmares
lady White Rabbit welcome and we're also
joined tonight by the third voice of
death mortis media hello everyone and
joining us today is everybody's favorite
waterproof corpse narrator please
welcome being scared
greetings you're listening to episode 8
of the dead stream in this episode we'll
talk about artificial intelligence
Horrors a new platform for our creators
and pewdiepie featured featuring a video
of our community also be taking your
questions from the chat later in the
broadcast
super chats will be definitely addressed
so one of the things that that we
discussed on Twitter this week was the
shelley AI horror thing so basically
what that is
it was a bot on Twitter that would
continue it would write a horror story
with you so you would write a tweet and
then say hashtag your turn and then the
bot would continue the story so we try
to start a story with Shelley but then
we realized that it hadn't posted at all
in 2018 and it looks like the bot might
be offline but what are you guys
opinions on artificial intelligence
writers horror stories idea I think it
could be really interesting if they can
be smart enough to write and respond
properly yeah it would certainly be an
interesting avenue to explore I agree I
was thinking about possibly if we could
get it working trying to write one and
seeing if it would contradict itself
like killing off a character and then
trying to because it seems like it seems
like it is able to
to continue the story and right back
like coherent responses that's actually
really cool I think yeah I quite like to
challenge it I'd quite like extremely
random try try and compete try and
confuse it there is a side of me that
thinks it's cool but there's also the
side of me that thinks about how it's
going to be used negatively and I could
see a lot of people using BOTS too right
just like a bunch of stories and get a
bunch of stuff out there and then kind
of flood the market with all of these
bots written stories that like probably
aren't gonna be very good at first and
then it's going to take away from like
the real human narrator or human writers
rather because then their stuff will be
buried under all that's true yeah I feel
like it maybe if a bot is writing that
many stories you could be able to maybe
decipher a pattern and be like oh this
is a bot written story yeah yeah there's
only so much that can go into it I feel
like in order to do that then you kind
of have to understand the like the
coding behind how the bot works here's a
little preview of it on Twitter so it
was writing quite a lot of stories I
guess it stopped like in November 17 and
it was supposedly doing them every hour
I don't know what what the the
motivation was for stopping it but I
don't know we've seen kind of a similar
thing on YouTube so where have you ever
seen those videos where it's like a news
video and it turns out to be one of
those text-to-speech voices yeah yeah I
think those videos are created by BOTS
and they just create as many as possible
around trending topics to try to get
views and money which i think is fun the
reason that we've seen the changes to
the partner program come recently
so that they have been a verified
because those people out of there are
those robots out of there because they I
think there's only so much originality
you can get from the bot I mean it's
like that rabbit said there's there's
gonna be like a pattern that all the
bots you know follow there's gonna be
you know it's an algorithm it's X Y or Z
and it's gonna go down sir roots and
it's just gonna be very genetic like
might one day it might be Susie was
walking down a lonely gravel road in the
middle of the night and there are a few
weeks later it might be Danny was
walking down the beach and yeah it'll
definitely have like a speech pattern or
like grammar that it always uses I mean
from what I read it was a little bit
better than that no no of course I mean
gonna be better but there are gonna be
things that are very similar that you
think are okay and this is sort of
similar to what I've read before I mean
I would definitely need to you know like
read a whole bunch of them I think
before you'd start detecting a pattern
but and then the other thing to think
about is if there is a pattern then like
what if what if we have real writers who
are writing a similar style and then
they end up getting dinged for it well
yeah but I think every writer has their
own unique flair
you know when they write it there
usually well I don't know what when I
read particular people's work you could
just tell by the language they use by
the you know the grammar that they
choose to deploy in certain situations
that you think okay this this sounds a
lot like this car they like this girl
but I you know wait back to your
original question I don't think that you
know there's any threat that the bots
would ever you know be too good and like
out match the writers that I still think
AI has a long way to go before it does
that maybe that's what the bats want you
to think well if they are so this was
the tweet that I sent out to try to get
it to respond to one Saturday afternoon
at 12:00
for youtubers were doing a show called
the dead stream I think it would have
been the beginning of a great horror
story but yeah maybe maybe one of us can
can finish that story in the future I
think I think that would be pretty
interesting maybe we can get every
horror narrator on YouTube to chip in a
line and see how far it goes that's a
good idea for a collab do you like a
telephone type of thing or not telephone
but yeah those things where everybody
contributes a little bit to the story
well I'll be trying to top each other at
the most bizarre sentence I was walking
along the beach and then he saw a
skinwalker and then someone else writes
but the skinwalker turned into the moon
then crushed Johnny until he was revived
tried to run away but he ran into tons
of bear traps oh wait that was already a
story we read
[Laughter]
oh I'm bringing the creature into it you
better believe it
so maybe when we do do that video it'll
be a good candidate for the upcoming
horror platform scream flicks which is a
new platform that's being developed by
mr. black pasta and s CRM radio who have
talked about before and supposedly it's
gonna be a horror basically a video
platform specifically for horror so what
are you guys thoughts on that sounds
cool sounds ambitious yeah sounds like
they have a long way to go yeah I mean
it's very hard to rival anything like
YouTube I mean everyone everyone who's
listening right now you know thanks for
coming but you know think think of the
practicalities that who here would think
are I'm gonna check out this other I'm
gonna check out screen flicks today
instead of YouTube you know it's really
hard to make something and have people
go over there and stick to it but I
think it's a great idea a great concept
and if he can get it to life they can
get it to work it will be you know
brilliant I'm sure you know I have high
hopes I really hope they can make it
work but it just depends it just depends
yeah I'll definitely be on it from day
one
I kind of agree with that is the other
thing about YouTube is that there are a
lot of people on it who don't even know
that they want to watch your video and
the the recomendation system is what
brings them in and introduces them to
the channel and then of course we talked
about vid me which was another video
platform that they they tried to do some
things differently than YouTube they
focused more on paid subscriptions than
advertising revenue and it was more it
was basically better customer support
for the creator and vid me was unable to
survive because they just couldn't
afford to keep the website running
because YouTube yeah so big it's the
problem when you're the when you get the
big fish in the pond you know sometimes
there's no room for other fish right so
here's a little look at what screen
flicks will supposedly look like I like
the design of it it looks it looks like
a clean good-looking design I agree yeah
you know it looks pretty fresh I mean
hopefully if nothing else you see like
the the videos there was like eleven
thousand views and stuff so if that
turns out to be true then I think it'll
be a success but I think if if they can
create it as something that can exist
alongside YouTube then we it'll be good
for all of us yeah I don't know about
turning it down at all just cuz it's not
YouTube I can be on multiple platforms
all day long exactly exactly
if it's something that kind of helps the
the die-hard horror fans become
introduced to our content mm-hmm I think
I think that's something that they have
to focus on is why would you want to go
to this other platform instead of
YouTube but I think the only way forward
is if they create only original content
that you can't get on YouTube I mean I
don't know if you remember a few months
ago when B Buster had a little meltdown
and say he's only gonna be straight yeah
we're only gonna be streaming on Twitch
he said yeah I'm gonna keep everything
there and I'm only gonna
which from now on and the appeal was
that everyone would go over to twitch in
order to keep watching him well if this
is gonna be a success you know mr. black
path darkness SCP radio are gonna have
to do a lot of exclusive only work for
the site in order to really push the
fans over right I don't know I feel like
trying to like we saw with me Busta that
that didn't really work and I feel like
doing having exclusive content over
there maybe isn't the way to go but but
at the same time if you have the same
thing that you've got on both what's the
appeal of going over there there's a
follower I just don't think that like
that's gonna be the purpose of it is for
people to abandon YouTube and go over
there I'm saying just to get from there
yeah yes so it's like there's more
appeal to go there and you know like do
both at the same time but at least allow
ah I'm gonna check out this other video
that's only available on here I mean
that's that's how you start building up
a little like community if they know
that but there's always good stuff there
to watch yeah I think you'd have to have
a lot of people already like on YouTube
like let's say hypothetically mister
nightmare said that he was gonna go over
there and he's only gonna upload some
video was on there then a good amount of
people would go there because he's got
so many subscribers you know what I mean
mmm I don't know I'm just I don't
understand I don't really know how it
would work what they really need to
figure out a way to make people go there
you know and it's it's got to be
something something that you type do you
know what they've been doing is like
taking suggestions on Twitter as to like
what can make this a better platform but
yeah I mean I do agree that if that the
audience isn't gonna ultimately be the
most important part is having having an
audience to reach there and then there
was also this this other platform or
tube which I've
only heard about from people who know
about it but do you know more about it
rabbit I am not heard about it though
who was it that said they Benny
something about it I it was it was me
it's a it's another platform it's it's
essentially the same thing as a CRM flix
it's just another platform to share
people's love for own to exclusive work
and to build up a new community on a
separate site that knows that it's
essentially the same thing but it's just
someone you know a few other people with
the same idea you know maybe they should
get in touch with it SCORM flix and see
if they can you know work together yeah
I mean the last thing that either of
them needs to be competing with each
other
exactly that's very counterproductive it
just makes sense to have what yeah yeah
yeah it's already such a specific
website for a specific need who might as
well combine forces exactly so there was
a tweet this our I guess this month by
Marga that raised an interesting
question that I wanted to talk about
should kids be watching our channels it
depends it depends on what kind of
what's in your content I've stopped you
when I first started my channel I would
occasionally say the f-word you know
what I mean but I don't anymore because
I've realized that there's got to be you
know I don't know how many but there's
got to be some children that listen to
listen to the the content sometimes and
I'd rather them not hear that stuff you
know but that's just my opinion I don't
know but but at the same time just
because you don't use profanities does
that mean does you know how would you
draw the line I mean in some of mine in
some of my stories I read I don't really
swear much either but when it comes to
certain stories they're so dark you know
they can be really twisted is that
already
not kid-friendly cuz I've had adults say
more dude this is too much yeah okay not
to me but you know because I read these
every day but if it's too bad for you
I'm sorry but yeah like it really it
really depends on what what's in the
story what's in the video you know yeah
because I I wrote a I wrote a short
story that was on my that's been that
was been on that that's on my channel
that I did about three months ago and
it's called eater
and it's about a guy that kidnapped
kidnapped somebody else and you know
cannibalizes him and it's extremely dark
and there's no way I would I would you
know in my opinion think that a child
should listen to that it just depends
you know I but on the other hand a lot
of my videos I specifically will I'll
take out the the f-word because it it
shows up and a lot of the stories that I
do and I'll just I'll just you know swap
it out for for like a different word
just to make it you know and I think in
most cases you can do that it really
just depends on the content I don't know
what do you think
I mean Shh should they be listening to
our content maybe maybe not I don't know
but there's content out there that's not
specifically horror stories it's more
educational that's just as dark talking
about you know serial killers in real
life little things to people and kids
are openly able to watch and listen to
that as well and they're not getting
punished for it at all because they're
an educational whose job do you think it
is to facilitate that do you think it's
your job to make kids aware that that
you do have dark content or do you think
it's it's the kids job or the parents
job to make sure that they're watching
stuff that they should be watching it's
probably a little bit on the parent so
we don't have like ratings on our
channel or anything well I mean I guess
do we have something that tells YouTube
that we have adult content don't we
yeah there's age restriction and you can
done once but if you if you just read
the title I'm you know some of our
videos you know I feel certain you
should be watching the light if you read
a title like most horrific stories
you'll ever you'll ever hear any
self-respecting parent isn't gonna be
like you know what that's a perfect
bedtime story I'm gonna give a
disclaimer before every video cuz I mean
kids are just gonna tune it out anyway
I've given disclaimers on only one of my
videos which was Brosco because it has
some serious messed up content in it
that I didn't want anybody walking
headfirst into that after two hours of
listening to me but then you don't want
to watch that stuff like it's the same
thing with like r-rated movies when we
were a kid we didn't we didn't grow up
with YouTube like you every video
honestly if you put I've put viewer
discretion advised in the at the
beginning of you know a few of my videos
and it probably has an opposite effect
and if you know there's a 12 year old
that's wanting to to hear something
crazy that that's probably what they're
looking for is something like that you
know yeah yeah don't push this button
yeah and honestly I don't feel because I
wasn't censored when I was a kid I was
able to watch pretty much anything but
there was no YouTube when I was a kid it
just horror movies but my parents let me
watch it and you know I don't know I
just as a parent now I'm just kind of
you know I wouldn't want my kids to
watch and listen to certain things on
YouTube but at the same time you can't
really censor them forever you know so I
think the one thing with the profanity
is I just think that
it's become more commonplace with kids
today yeah it seems like that's just
kind of just something that's not as big
of a deal as it used to be I don't put
it in my videos because I want like if
my phone video gets demonetised I want
to have all the right excuses for it not
to be to be ramana Thais essentially but
yeah I do think that there's kind of
like a lower level or a higher level of
tolerance that like I guess maybe the
older generations don't understand like
whenever you see YouTube in the news for
for doing crazy stuff they don't really
understand that like these kids are
connected and they do they do know those
words and stuff yeah I want to give a
big thank you to Eric how do you
pronounce that Mar mark parks and Mark
Marquette apologies if I'm not
pronouncing that correctly but big thank
you to him for the generous super chat
donation he says hey cz and Lady White
Rabbit you all have given me hours of
entertainment and I just wanted to share
the love PS not sure who the other nerds
are but I'll check him out and yeah
definitely do go check him out they're
both very very talented narrators right
oh thanks Eric
so the next the next topic we're going
to talk about is kind of a difficult
subject to talk about because we're
gonna try to avoid any spoilers and it's
something that those other two nerds
aren't familiar with at the time but
we're gonna talk about as long as we're
on the topic of virtual horrors for this
for this episode we're going to talk
about doki-doki literature Club I think
we brought it up once last stream rabbit
brought it up and then I went and played
it since then and I thought it was like
absolutely a masterpiece so I'm gonna go
ahead and play the trailer for that and
we'll have a little discussion
afterwards there's the disclaimer
warning
[Music]
for those of you here completely
confused right now I swear it it does
relate to horror just give it another 30
seconds
[Music]
so yeah actually now that I think about
it the trailer doesn't really pertain to
horror at all no but that's supposed to
like really do it I suppose yeah I mean
that's one of the things that I loved
about it is how it just kind of bends
the genre when did the words value but
yeah without spoiling anything basically
it starts off as like a typical Japanese
dating simulator and it kind of gets
more and more disturbing as you go so
rabbit I wanted to ask like like what
your experience was with it oh did you
did you go after any one of the girls in
particular at the beginning and yeah
what was your experience with the
playthrough well first of all I heard
about it from the game grumps I watched
them play up until things just start
getting dark and then I had to stop
because I was like no more spoilers I
need to play this game for myself okay
um I went after Yuri because she's my
girl she's really quiet and reserved
that I like her and if ever they voiced
these characters I would a hundred
percent wanna voice her oh that's a good
idea but yeah yeah I also I also was
like more interested in going after Yuri
but at the point of my first playthrough
because I also kind of had the same
experience where I had watched like some
video on YouTube to familiarize with
myself with it and I just saw like the
beginning like the first dark part and
then I want to go play it for myself but
I didn't know how intelligent the AI
wasn't that oh yeah like if there wasn't
a AI or if it was just a story so I kind
of I kind of like I would talk to the
other girls to try to see how Yuri would
react
mm-hm and I don't think in the end that
it made a difference yeah I think if you
start going towards netsuke and then
veer away you'll get a specific event
but that's the only thing I know that
does that it's kind of interesting
because when I first played it through
when things start getting crazy with URI
I started getting like I was like alone
in my house at night playing this game
and I started getting like scared of her
so I started like confiding in Monica
not knowing what her whole role in the
entire storyline was and I was like
please save me I'm gonna hide behind you
now so when you had like that when
they're preparing for the festival or
whatever and you have like the take home
project did you have that with URI yes I
did okay so what was that way because I
ended up doing it with I believe it was
not Sookie so the first time around when
you go home and hang out with URI she
comes over with a bunch of incense and a
knife and starts talking about how she
has like a collection of knives and you
end up pricking your finger in which she
licks the blood from it so that's kind
of like the foreshadowing of where she's
going with that does that with the
society show up during that say Oriya
yeah show she'll always I think she
always shows up the same way okay the
only difference is how you spend the
weekend with which girl interesting if
you guys haven't played that one then I
would definitely recommend checking that
out I'm looking in the chat right now
someone's talking about spider-man web
shooters oh yeah are you guys following
that seeing something about that one of
my favorite memes from like 2006 or 2007
is the spider-man triple action web
blasters let commercials just like so
over-the-top and funny to me it's like
if it it's it has like a very early 2005
there was another game that I played
recently which kind of reminded me of
doki-doki literature club which was
called duck season have you guys heard
about that I've heard of it but I have
no idea what it is I have not so it's a
VR game it was actually developed by a
youtuber
Brandon Jala
who used to be a part of rocket jump
which is Freddie w's company video game
high school but yeah he started his own
VR video game company and came out with
this game called duck season so I mean
we're all familiar with duck hunt on the
NES right yes
yeah so it's basically in the game
you're a kid from the 80s your mom rents
the game duck hunt and she brings home
like a haunted cartridge and the dog
from the game starts haunting you in
real life oh yeah I think yeah you told
me about this and I was intrigued if I
ever got a VR yeah I'm gonna go ahead
and play a trailer for this one as well
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so the cool thing about that that's
similar to doki-doki is it starts off as
just a regular game and I think you play
like three rounds of just a regular duck
shooting game before things start to get
weird oh wow but that looks like an 80s
fever dream yeah it's awesome because
like you you play in the oculus and then
like when you put that thing on it's
amazing cuz you really feel like you're
in there moreso than like watching a 360
video on YouTube like you when you're in
the game you really feel like you're in
it and you can interact with almost
everything and like playing that game I
really felt like it was going into a
time machine and going back to the
eighties that's awesome yeah and I
wasn't even around for the 80s but I
still find that found myself like having
nostalgia for it yeah it's it's kind of
what stranger things did yeah so in your
opinion is the oculus the best VR device
um I haven't used them all but it's
probably the best one that I've used and
they're gonna continue to get a lot
better yeah next few years because right
now it's it's a high resolution by
considering that it's it's wrapped all
the way around you what you're actually
looking at at any one given moment isn't
that high so like once once the the
technology gets better then it's gonna
be really amazing and probably like hard
to differentiate out of real life I
honestly yeah it's the stereotypical
thing of like a movie where you go into
the video game and then you don't want
to come out I honestly got that when I
was like I just wanted to say and
explore that world it was really cool
that's awesome you have heard great
things that I'm just definitely waiting
for you know the peak of VR technology
for me to go out and get one
but yeah the games like super scary
because you're playing the game and then
it becomes apparent that the dog has
like crossed over into real life and you
keep turning around because you don't
know where he's gonna be it could be an
impression and then there's like weird
stuff like I want
well too much of it but like for example
we were playing it I was playing with a
couple friends and there's like a photo
that's on your wall and then after a
while like I was just looking around and
doing my thing and analyzing different
parts of the apartment things you missed
and I noticed the dog was like in this
picture yeah that's awesome
we noticed that we were so freaked out
[Laughter]
yeah there's definitely a huge platform
for horror in VR I can't wait for it
mmm yeah it does seem to be more akin to
gaming than it does for video mm-hmm but
yeah I would like to do a video at one
point
are you hungry there being scared yes
so our next topic is PewDiePie talked
about one of the videos from someone in
the horror community I'm gonna need a
second to bring this up have you guys
seen this no I heard about that really
really cool yeah so PewDiePie does this
thing called a meme review so he did a
video about it was on February 6 so
about a month ago and he reviewed one of
chills slash top 15 videos and it's
since become like a pretty big meme I
think I've seen like I posted something
on Twitter and people were making
references to it like I said right at
this yeah I'll just go ahead and play
the video this meme is fantastic it
started from 15 channel making a video
of the top 50 mysteries solved by
fortune in the very first video BAE
begins like this Burger King foot
lettuce the last thing you'd want in
your Burger King burger is someone's
foot fungus but as it turns out that
might be what you get number how does he
do that stupid voice number 15 no num
number 50
number 15 Burger King foot lettuce the
last thing you want in your burger king
burger is foot fungus but as it turns
out that might be what you get why does
he talk like that and why I have so many
questions the observed absurdity observa
t absurdity of this clip made for some
nice some names here it's done in a
silly Pig last thing you'd want in your
burger king burger in someone's flowing
guinness completely turning the video
around incredible it used to be so
spooky I think there's more I don't know
why it's funny it's so dumb there's of
course that number 9 Big Smoke wandering
get the idea yeah so pretty funny mean
but what do you guys think is this is
this good for the horror community
getting more exposure after the biggest
channel on YouTube or our people just
not gonna take it seriously now well
sure I mean it's probably good exposure
for they he didn't actually promote
anything particularly creepy or horror
so I don't think it will have a huge
boom or be particularly helpful he just
when he took the piss off yeah so I
think it probably is good for chills a
lot of people will oh yeah sure good for
chills but you know how when did the
video come out a month ago you know I
think I need to like see if chills
spiked or anything yeah yeah he's a
pretty big channel anyway but just in
terms of memes being scared what grade
would you give it
a seven out of ten
yeah seven tacos out of ten seven
hundred tacos I know I know what we're
doing after the stream yeah Taco Bell
yeah I do think it's kind of interesting
because it's something that I've noticed
for a while
where there are a lot of youtubers
especially commentary youtubers who kind
of talk and they don't end their
sentence and I think that's kind of what
Joe was doing here yeah and it's just
like a really good example of it and
that's why he's very dry very yeah I did
notice that whatever listened to some of
his videos I loved him boy you you loved
his voice I do it's really unique and I
don't know it just goes really well with
the with the top you know the top lists
that he does in mine I think I used to
really like his voice when I saw his
foot I think I saw his first ever video
and I really liked him but I don't know
when he did the collaboration with Rob
Dyke when his voice was compared to
Rob's like oh my god you need to just
listen to him on his own you can't you
can't when you listen to him it's okay
but when you can put him next to someone
else you just feel like oh yeah yeah
that's just me I actually just asked him
if he would if he would join me in a
video and he said yes so that's gonna be
yeah I think Nick Nocturne does kind of
a similar thing there's actually a video
a while ago I don't remember which one
but like I was watching Nick Nocturne
and you know you guys know Nick's
channel right
and I mind yes to where he's kind of
like hello everybody and welcome to
night mind that like I was listening to
him and then I was narrating my video
and I found myself kind of doing that
No so I think every recorded or
something what not that's bad not that
that's bad he has a very he has a very
pleasing voice the same thing in mine
you should do an entire video and just
try to mimic chills as best you can and
then let's see what happens
yeah I should do it and I'll take
requests I should write one about the
different narrators oh yes and then do
impersonations of their voices oh god no
I don't think that that I'd be able to
imitate yours rabbit but it may I can
maybe get whoever does the voice from
Ouran High School Host Club it's not so
rabbit but it's so our next story is
kind of a part two of something that
we've covered before but our good friend
southern cannibal has done another face
reveal of the top half of the face so
we're all gonna give our grade to uh
like out of top ten tacos my haircut
million tacos so rabbit how many tacos
are you giving southern cannibals new
haircut mm give it a solid seven and a
half tacos cuz I ate the other half of
the taco all right being scared there
you go six tacos six hours
he's eating more of the taco he would
have given seven but he ate one of them
we only have so many was gonna give him
ten but I ate four of them yeah and more
if you have any tacos left at this point
I'm gonna give him five I'll give him
eight tacos and one taquito
because I you know that's like getting a
curly fry and with your regular fries
did you guys hear about meat locker no
so yeah he he posted a tweet a while ago
and it's it's since been deleted because
he took down his Twitter but he said
I've been so busy with two jobs that
I've given up on YouTube lost my will to
even bother but I've been blessed with a
new job one that can pay my bills put me
in a house and more importantly I'll be
able to annoy your eardrums again with
new videos well that's great so he's not
quitting YouTube then he said that and
then he deleted all his profiles except
for his YouTube which he changed the
name of it to gray god which you can see
here yeah and yeah he's gone now Oh
interesting so that seems very strange
to me that he said he was going to be
put it seems like a lot of people do
this actually where they say they're
gonna be posting more and then I don't
know what happens like the pressure gets
to them or something and then they just
totally go am ia yeah
it sounds like he's happy with what he's
doing though yeah that's that's the
that's the important part well he also
took down all of his videos well I mean
is his jobs that he's talking about
something that couldn't pay his bills
yeah I don't know it seems strange to me
though that he would say he's coming
back and then just completely disappear
why would he take down all of his videos
but still leave his channel that's weird
yeah that is that is a little strange
and like changed the whole name and
branding of it yeah well maybe there's
something huge on the horizon for him
yes maybe maybe he's good boss I was
just gonna say maybe he's gonna send us
loads of tacos and that's his new career
a couple things in the chat I can
address actually like we could probably
start taking questions now before we hit
our last few stories and our
our narration for the day but looking at
the chats tickle me Trish 13 says let's
did a pretty good southern cannibal
impersonation are you talking about
let's read I just read that - that's
interesting I would really like to hear
that yeah
CeCe's world should inherit the channel
maybe he's gonna upload a ten-hour story
oh boy
I mean I don't even know I don't know
what I would do if I inherited meat
lockers Channel oh I'm just noticing how
did you make a ten-hour story did you
guys notice this is just number one
pictures of raw meat that's nice that's
a good one guys how do you feel about
the horror community as a whole what do
you mean by how we read wow that's a big
big question is a vague question I think
it's a great community I think it's one
of the best communities on YouTube I
think whenever you look at like people
doing collaborations and supporting each
other that we have like some of the most
interaction out of anybody and like some
of the most positive support I agree I'm
not a part of any other community so I
have no idea but I enjoy being a part of
it and I think it's pretty cool yeah do
you guys watch other youtubers outside
of the community I do yeah who do you
get who are you guys yeah I watch
WatchMojo oh I watch angry Joe he does
review some new games and movies pretty
actually you know pretty much just the
Oh occasionally I would watch good
mythical morning yeah that's my Joe
please
yeah I love
I love those guys they're awesome what
about you Martin
well I listen to a lot of I hate
everything oh yeah I find him incredibly
funny I think we talked about him on the
show before yeah yeah it's just it's
just really funny and I'm also like a
super Pokemon go nerd so I'm really
really in that community but I doubt
very few people who the whole community
do that but yeah they've got a good
community going on I don't think it's as
collaborative as the horror could be
Beauty mmm rabbit a lot of gaming stuff
I'm a huge fan of the game grumps a good
mythical morning like I said your movie
sucks is great and recently I've been
getting big into defunct land
what's defunct Lana it is a channel that
basically just talks about the history
of roller coasters that went out of
commission and why and it's a dude who's
trying to make a VR Park of all the
defunct rides pretty cool really excited
about it
yeah check that one out because I'm a
huge roller coaster fan and I used to do
like those VR coasters oh no oh yeah for
sure you'd love this channel yeah
there's a couple more that I just
thought of that I don't I don't know why
I didn't think of these too but
cinemasins have you guys heard of that
oh yeah yeah that channel is hilarious I
love that channel and also screen
junkies yeah really good Channel I'm not
a huge fan of cinemasins or your movie
sucks because I feel like like their
whole career is just like crapping on
movies they look for anything they do
yeah says that he even says I know I'm
an [ __ ] but what I do but if you if
you watch enough of the episodes he'll
actually like if he he'll admit when he
really like
something and he'll say you know what
this is so cool that I'm gonna take off
five sins or whatever something you know
what I mean yeah yeah but yeah I don't
know yeah I don't know I guess I just
prefer like to like I love bad movies
but I prefer to give attention to the
ones that are good I do too
someone came up with a parody channel
called cinema wins I don't know how well
it did but I knew I know it's out there
yeah I've tried watching it it's it's
the opposite he's just pointing out
everything that he loves and it's not
honestly I'm being honest like it's a
it's a much nicer channel but it's not
nearly as entertaining for me when when
people just like watch these movies and
list things it doesn't really do it for
me so like I I obviously have things you
missed but with that I try to say like
why is this important to the movie why
is this like psychologically relevant
and yeah kind of go a little bit deeper
with it mmm
as for me I watch a bunch of I watch a
lot of YouTube my favorite channel is
Dax flame who is like one of the og
youtubers but he was basically like vlog
channel where he was like the the
awkward kid in school and he would do
vlogs about like all the weird stuff
that he would get into and he's always
in character he's been in in like real
Hollywood movies he's always in
character but he doesn't post a whole
lot anymore i watch a lot of keemstar i
like to keep up to date with what's
going on on YouTube and I think he's
really entertaining and one that I've
been watching a lot recently is called
yes theory yeah yes theory that great
yeah he's really cool so they do like
how would you describe the their channel
so if you've seen the film Yes Man it's
about a guy who just says yes and does
you know things that's gonna improve his
life well they they
of their way to put themselves in
uncomfortable situations and you know
embrace life to do really random wacky
funny things and it's really funny like
they they made an episode of you I don't
know how old it is but because I already
just recently found them they just on a
Wednesday they were like okay you know
what today we're gonna find a stranger
asked to host a dinner party at their
house and invite other strangers and
it's gonna be great and then a time and
it was brilliant and I was like oh my
god why can't I be doing this I need to
see that that sounds really cool yeah I
remember then I live in London and you
know if I do that I'll probably get
stabbed
it's called yes theory yeah they did
that uh like right over here in Venice
yeah yeah my favorite video that they
did was when they tried to sneak into
places by wearing yellow vests I haven't
seen that one like you know there's a
like construction worker or electric
yellow vests so they just put those on
and they snuck into a bunch of movie
theaters and they snuck into like a
restaurant and that was the only one
where they got caught and then they
snuck into a theme park they snuck in a
universal oh my gosh really yeah how
they just walked right through the exit
wearing those vests and nobody
questioned them oh but but you know what
I think the greatest thing is they
challenged Will Smith because will smell
a house it you know to jump out of a
helicopter you know to bungee head to
heli bungee and he replied and he
accepted and yeah they're budging over
the Grand Canyon there I'm actually
going to the Grand Canyon soon so I'm
hoping don't they do it at the same time
that I'm there
you should just what why don't you say
listen up I'm a fellow youtuber and I
want to be a part of the experience and
who knows they might even say yes and
you could just be there yeah as part of
their work traj do it there's there's
this kid that shows up to the YouTube I
think he was in the
earlier his name's elixir but he he
actually like just showed up at their
house cuz they did this video where they
showed up at billionaires houses and
tried to have Donuts with them so he did
that same thing to them and yeah they
they let him in and he made the video
and they had he had donuts with them
also yeah but enough about yes theory do
we have any other questions that we want
to address there's a seven-foot white
rabbit outside my house what should I do
I just leave it alone give it some tacos
everything will be fine I mean it sounds
like maybe a possible sequel to two duck
season rabbit season or wabbit season
wabbit season Gigi gaming says should I
become spider-man yes if you have the
opportunity I would recommend it
hi becoming spider-man yeah definitely
don't do that just remain an average
person like the rest of us oh we got
another donation from Eric a truck
he's a truck driver so he had to stop to
reply oh wow that's dedications thanks a
lot babe do you all share that she's
super chat pay yes we do if not to
mortise media scary readings and Lady
white rabbit have pitch around what I do
yes we talked about the story behind
that right oh where my patreon came from
yeah I think we talked about it yeah I
was like the first dead stream I think
but yeah thanks again to Eric we really
appreciate the contribution yes thank
you and that's awesome that you that you
listen to the dead stream like while
you're while you're out truckin because
I'm like it's become more more video
centric now I guess but I've always
wanted it to work as an audio thing as
well so where you can just listen to it
because that's how I consume a lot of my
content yeah
were there any other questions that we
wanted to address before we move on I
think good okay yeah so we're getting up
to close to an hour here but we should
talk about the darks omniums WWE horror
streams hilarious have you guys seen any
of them no I want to really bad okay
he's he's done one so far and it was a
few weeks ago and I'm just gonna play it
with no sound in the background here
while we talk about this but basically I
don't know he like he modded this this
WWE 17 fighting game or something and he
created like all of our avatars from the
horror community no way yeah so then he
ended up having this huge like battle
royale type of thing so this one is
let's read verses insomniac God yes if
you basically I think he just creates
the characters and then puts it on
stream and he commentates while they
fight it out and he just lets them go at
it I think I think we all know that the
winner out of everyone will be killer
orange care no actually so he did the
tournament last time
and the winner ended up being me really
yeah that's amazing king of the horror
community for a day wow that is great
and the hilarious thing was my first
match was against the dark somnium I'm
pretty sure I just destroyed him I had
no idea this even existed like look at
the size of the wrath and oh my god do
you know who would I believe let's read
one this one if I remember correctly it
was well yeah but when he's doing it he
does like the full commentary like oh he
grabs his head
oh and he's about to slam it down Wow oh
and the other thing he drinks while he's
doing it
oh he's only AK he's actually doing
another one tonight I believe I think
it's tonight Wow can we just leave this
playing so we talked about that Shelley
a I think at the beginning of the stream
they didn't it didn't continue our story
obviously but we just found a story that
it wrote so I thought it would be kind
of interesting to spice it up and read
that instead so we're gonna have being
scared and Lady White Rabbit narrating
this a I've written Horror Story so the
parts that that being scared narrates
are the parts that the bots wrote and
then the parts that rabbit narrates are
gonna be the parts that the the human
twitter users wrote is that right oh I
thought it was the other way no no I
think the bolt is to buy it yeah that's
what I called that's what I said right
no or in this case being scared is the
butt okay oh I see okay you guys can't
see the text but it's bold and that spot
and lady right rabbits gonna read that
okay so I am the bot got it cool and if
he was throwing any wrestling announcing
during generation you're welcome to it
looked at me and said something to me
that I couldn't even look away from it's
time to him the last time I heard that
mom passed away with no family left
alive who could it mean was that my mom
what did she beam I never wanted to see
the same face again but it was her it
was mom but she's been dead for over 10
years slowly I realized that can only
mean one thing
I was about to get punished I felt
worried but I also knew nothing would
equal the pain I caused her I turned to
the figure that I used to call mom and
begged for mercy it looks like let's
rate is also getting punished right now
[Laughter]
she just stared at me at that moment I
was sure I was going to die the same way
I didn't have the right to speak but I
could tell I was surrounded by doctors
and nurses at least I hoped that's what
they were still unable to move I could
still feel everything including the
first slice from the scalpel and the
leather-like scales on its six fingers
and then I realized that I was still
alive my mind still in uncontrollable
danger and my body felt like it was
going to although I now knew it was my
time I could choose to go peacefully or
I could continue to fight I made my
decision and I slowly died I was
overcome I was overcome by a relief that
I had never felt before
relief that was short-lived when the
monstrous figure rose from the flames
and said welcome to hell
Tim your cell awaits the wall was
completely empty except for the fire pit
the flames start started at the same
time as I was on the ground suddenly I
saw hundreds of poor souls being
tortured in flames I guess I was really
in hell I was in shock I didn't know
what to do I was literally shaking from
the fire I tried to scream but I
couldn't find my voice as I stared at
the flames the fire grew darker and
darker as the fire grew brighter I
imagine the fire started to fade and
then I woke up in a hospital bed I was
shaking and all I could see
was by needles and the blood and sticks
in my fingers what then
that bastard came into my room I
instantly knew what had happened and why
I was being he why I was here
he always was at fault but the only
thing I could think of was that he was
alive and that he was going to get me I
felt so sure of that and look what
you've done
he yelled at me you ruined my experiment
again can't you get anything right
he continued raving more stories HTTP
[Laughter]
scariest part of all yeah if you're
interested in checking out more there's
a website stories ledi the story doesn't
really go anywhere but it seems like the
bots actually kind of pushed it further
like push the story forward more than
the human yeah yeah didn't it didn't
even start falling apart until the fire
started fluctuating and how it was going
yeah but like it was pretty coherent
like the person would bring up like a
male character Tim and then it seemed
like it was it was consistent the bots
responses were consistent yeah but yeah
definitely a long way to go before it's
it's able to rival like a human writer I
think that's something that we should do
in the future is just do like sentence
horror stories with each other you know
it's to be really cool and I definitely
want to stop halfway into a sentence and
have the other person finish it and the
sticks in his fingers like that just
sounds like the rake or something oh
yeah like it sounds like a description
of one of those creepypasta creatures
creatures I should say yeah that's
definitely one of the creatures any
other thoughts on the AI horror story
before we wrap things up
I just know excited to see where it goes
yeah let's let's do a couple more things
from the chat so Harry is asking is this
a program that I can use I think he's
talking about the the the wrestling
stream right I don't know if that's what
you're talking about Harry it looks like
it's a video game
like WWE 2k 18 or something and that
he's just modded it to include all these
characters some of them actually looked
pretty similar too so who it's supposed
to be
he means the AI story Oh
oh my god Eric you're paying for all of
my tacos dude I Drive 10 hours a day and
horny waiters get b-36 thanks happy to
oblige
yeah that's that's 50 tacos right there
I was like to say taco you're getting
ripped off
Sosa's world I'm a you know I have
PayPal and I'm pretty sure Mort does too
and you know however you want to split
this up is totally cool
[Laughter]
I was just joking as for the was he as
for the AI program it was a bot that you
could interact with on Twitter but it
doesn't look like it's working anymore
but if it ever becomes active again then
we'll definitely have to do a dead
stream story oh for sure oh and then
there was one other oh yeah people keep
bringing up like you guys should bring
up or you guys should check out found
flicks he's a horror youtuber except he
does movies I've never really watched
one of found flicks as videos but I just
know like whenever I upload a things you
missed then he like he uploads something
that's like extremely similar to it like
I'll do things you missed in
jigsaw and then he'll do like details
you missed in jigsaw and it'll come out
like a couple days after so I don't
really know about that but I I haven't I
haven't like looked in depth at his
content he could have completely
different things that I didn't talk
about for all I know but it does seem
suspicious to me reword everything you
say to sound like he's a an off-brand
version of you yeah like when when I
started doing things you missed and it
started to get popular I noticed there
were like a bunch of even like a bunch
of big channels who started just like
taking my titles and thumbnails and
descriptions and doing like their own
just barely altered version like even
WatchMojo was doing it oh yeah it was
very strange
frosty pen and paper on line says search
for some creepy stuff from Mother Russia
should I do it yes yes be stuff from
[Laughter]
tonight in five minutes all right so
this is Pinterest side story about
Pinterest there you guys do you guys
have time to stay for a while to do a
side story suppose we're starting
earlier I keep getting these weird
recommendations from Pinterest and I
posted some of them on Twitter so I got
like Pinterest recommends me anime boys
I don't know where it comes up with us
and then I started like recommending
these weird anime ships like I do I do
probably look up anime things but not
like those specific things so it's just
been giving me like all these weird and
recommendations recently
and Soviet Russia Pokemon catch you none
of them looked creepy they just look
like memes yeah yeah do you guys have
any experience with Pinterest you know I
used it from time to time but it's not
something I quickly yeah I tried to use
it awhile year to promote my YouTube
stuff but they stopped accepting youtube
links have you ever used it being scared
I have not no so here's some more creepy
rather Mother Russia memes these are
kind of creepy just the faces look very
uh very bony I guess these people look
like they're in some serious distress oh
my gosh whoa dude alright I feel like
you need to do something special for
Eric I got uh Eric I'm doing a
livestream in exactly one week do you do
have anything you want to stalk about
Eric yeah dude you've got the spotlight
man while we wait for him to respond
we'll look at some more creepy Russian
propaganda memes Harry's like Eric what
are you guys you got a pleasure him
órale you know at this point Harry
Susie is volunteering Eric I just want
to say if you ever pop on my channel and
you have a particular topic you want me
to cover you know just just message down
and I'll I'll make a video no you can
say this is miss aspheric this is Eric I
think I've made more off of Eric today
than I have of just YouTube in general
yeah no kidding on that one
let's look up some images oh this looks
interesting
he's the hero this dead stream deserves
yeah
what are you um let's let's look at some
of the other questions how do you guys
like strangers pray at night I haven't
seen it yeah and I actually haven't seen
the original strangers but maybe you
guys can speak on that I really like the
strangers and I can't wait for the
sequel the original is fantastic I
haven't seen yet what's what's the
premise of it I 2 people are home alone
in a house like in the woods kind of
away from other people and these 3
masked figures start just tormenting
them breaking into their house just just
generally terrifying them for no other
reason than they were home right ok
looking at like the aesthetic of the new
movie it did give me a little bit of
vibes from the purge but I know the
strangers came out before that right
yeah yeah the masks I think may have
been inspired by the strangers Erik just
says banks declining me now lol Erik if
you have anything you want us to talk
about will be on here for a couple more
minutes so let us know and yeah follow
us on all of our social medias and hit
us up yeah please do what was the other
question and Soviets Russia otaku pay
for you do you know D jet slow happening
well I don't know what that means let's
look it up
I don't get you kids in your speaking
there's no D jet low but D at Slav was I
guess some incident in Russia Oh Diablo
oh yeah more you probably know more
about this than we do because of
proximity well is it something that my
brother topi but I never I never
researched him I think it's you know
this I couldn't a mountain or something
or like a hill and you know when people
go through that I disappeared or there
was a team of people who disappeared in
this past and I really have explained
that's about oh is that is that their
faces I guess they they were found and
they were dead yeah I actually did you
want it's like a year ago oh yeah
yeah it's pretty interesting actually
pretty scary yeah they all just they
were all just found like dead and I
guess somebody was missing a tongue and
there's just no way I you know what
happened to them it's really creepy
that's interesting and then this is a
Yeti from Diablo Pass
of course it's blurry because every uh
every supernatural photo is always
blurry what do you guys think that the
tongue was used for it maybe soup soup
tongue soup I mean if I wasn't gonna
resort to cannibalism that's probably
not the first thing I would go for what
would you go for that's a good question
yeah tell me all about how are you at
cannibalize somebody I mean it seems
logical to go for like something
something meaty you know yeah yeah like
there's I don't know like there yeah
definitely part of there
I'm thinking there's probably some
primate on those shoulder blades you got
to remember though in Mother Russia
they'd be other parts first yeah how
many good back and forth of them
[Laughter]
frosty also says there was a bunch of
radioactive material on them and nobody
knows why man good old good ol Russia GG
gaming says is Eric mr. beast which is
mr. beast is a youtuber who does all
these what he does all these videos
where he like crashes and on streams and
donates like tons of money or like he
did one recently where he donated a
bunch of pennies to someone like a
hundred thousand pennies or something oh
wow that could be Eric could be mr.
beast in disguise for all we know if it
is we figured it out hashtag exposed all
right any last things you guys want to
hit before we wrap it up mm I think so I
think being scared hit is it 40k or the
milestones today yeah so being scared
was it have you only hit 41 or 42 I mean
you're on fire like I can't even keep
track if I had just hit 41 well dump man
seriously Congrats
yeah thank you yeah being scared
channels been blowing up he did he
started started with the scary stories
to listen to in the rain right yes and
then it's like where did it go from
there how did you capitalize on that
well I did the first one and people
liked it and people just commented and
said that they would like me to do more
and I did and people liked it that was
pretty much it
so congratulations into being scared on
that also we had let's
hit 300,000 whoa yeah legit that's
awesome I think I first started talking
to let's read when he had like 30,000 so
it's been awesome to watch him grow and
find an audience like that yeah and I
don't turn around hit 200,000 Wow nice
actually I actually just learned about
him like a week ago and this channel is
really cool yeah for those of you who
don't know I think most of my audience
doesn't know because we've been doing a
cross-promotion recently with in the
community tab but for those who are
familiar he is most known for doing
creepy texting stories so instead of
doing narrations you see yeah yeah
they're pretty cool that's really yeah
pretty cool he did one recently that I
really liked in particular he did
texting stories with YouTube celebrities
at VidCon and it was like there was a
maniac going around VidCon hunting down
these youtubers so he had like Jake Paul
and Logan Paul and then like keemstar
and rice gum jumped into it PewDiePie it
was a fun story yeah so that is all of
the time we have for this episode of the
dead stream
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]